ce collecteur d'eaux pluviales à plus
d'une cinquantaine d'années c'est l'un
des plus anciens du centre ville de fort
de france
installé sous la chaussée il est depuis
dix ans très endommagés à cause du
passage régulier des véhicules depuis
juillet l'installation du nouveau qu'un
niveau est en cours
l'ouvragé hydraulique en dalles
préfabriquées est plus moderne et mieux
calibrée pour recueillir les eaux
pluviales et limiter les risques
d'inondations
le nouveau collecteur d'eaux pluviales
permet en fait un écoulement plus aisés
il est beaucoup plus grand que
l'original
donc l'effet de flux et reflux est
quelque part diminué et donc on a on a
une rue de la liberté qui sera beaucoup
plus opérationnel et aussi plus
confortable puisque lorsqu'on va
l'emprunter on aura plus l'effet de
gondole qu'on avait au préalable
en plus du changement du collecteur
d'eaux pluviales ces travaux consistent
également à l'aménagement et
l'embellissement de la voirie la ville
allait un beau projet donc et profitant
du changement du collector donc il y
aura une amélioration de l'assemblée de
la chaussée et surtout une attention
particulière a été donnée aux piétons
puisque à chaque travée à chaque angle
de rue y aura une plateau surélevé pour
permettre le franchissement de la voie
toute sécurité pour les piétons
les travaux sont effectués en trois
tronçons afin de préserver l'activité
des professionnels du secteur et limiter
la gêne liée au chantier
et pourtant les clients ne viennent pas
part aux travaux
face à un détour c'est vraiment gênant
pour eux et pour nous tourner à notre
côté on le devine ici alors les martins
lane est attendu chez nous à des balades
et là ils ont pris toujours à l'honneur
au bruit même les amis oui nous pouvons
aller faut la commencer mi juillet la
fin des travaux est prévue au début du
mois de novembre